e
Jam who
is
yeah he will
be good morning everyone uh can I ask uh
please thank you welcome everyone to
legislative Administration we have a
whole new cast of characters today some
old friends um some new friends um
welcome our representative tandel bomb
mandle bomb
um you're only going to see for a short
period of time here but you're you're
more than welcome um and participate as
much as you can others I have uh I've
worked with in the past I don't know if
everyone else has um actually we
represented the evil we've I don't know
how many different committees we've uh
been together on um we also o have
representative tersi that I was on
Transportation with and representative
Fox that I'm currently on Transportation
with um so uh it's nice to have familiar
faces
um we also have another special guest
in y and we
um okay we good um we also have rep kill
um who is will be substituting and I
think when the exec session begins um
we'll have representative n will be in
on the Republican side um the plan of
attack today is uh we only have our last
two bills um both Senate bills obviously
Senate Bill 605 which deals with um with
ethics and uh we also have the other
bill um that deals with the portrait for
Senator Martha full Clark um and we're
waiting for an amendment on that so
hopefully that arrives before we get uh
anticipating much of a problem um with
any of the Amendments that I've seen um
are there any other amendments that
anyone has that that we want to talk
about repres representative trki you
have an amendment or no
coming okay um dealing with what what I
would like to do is take up 605 first
dealing with the ethics um the amendment
is for 605 excellent um so let's uh
let's jump into the work session um and
we can have dueling amendments going
here um I have a feeling my prior
knowledge is that um
605 Amendment um 1669 here will take
care of yours so yes that's my that's my
secret information we'll see um so with
that I'm going to hand
out and I should explain a little bit
too while this is going out the the
process that we've gone through um that
goes that way this goes that way
um you should be extras if you want to
just leave them down at the end rep box
if you can leave whatever's extra just
at the
table
um are we still missing one or
page yeah that's right you would have
um the only piece of information after
the the hearing that we had uh a couple
weeks
ago the that was done two or three days
prior to the ethics committee meeting um
I attended the Ethics Committee uh
meeting and they were nice enough to
push me to the top of the agenda and we
discussed this bill
the amendment that you have before you
is a
direct
um understanding of what was discussed
at that Ethics Committee meeting so the
changes that I'll point out to you came
from that Ethics Committee meeting um
and this will be the first time that
we've heard
them I would I don't have one um
thank you I'll first point
to the the uh the I think there's four
total changes the first is beginning on
line
eight um in the original Bill
organizations uh were defined in this
section beginning on line
five and beginning on line seven they
excluded the United States of America
the state of New Hampshire and a county
within New Hampshire that was that's
where it ended in the original bill this
amendment ads or any political
subdivision within the state of New
Hampshire the reason for that change um
was a discussion that our house uh um
attorney had with the Senate attorney
asking why political subdivisions
weren't included in that um that
list and the answer was that we received
back was well we left them off because
they wouldn't have qualified anyway
because they weren't receiving Financial
remuneration by any organization in line
13 so he was under the impression that
they weren't paid um any of the
Selectmen Fire Chiefs and so on all the
way down water Commissioners and
everything else were it it was his
assumption that those positions weren't
paid so therefore they wouldn't qualify
under this anyway so when it was pointed
out that they do get paid in some
instances Alderman
um it was necessary to add that back in
so that's why you see or any political
subdivision within the state of New
Hampshire that's change number one and
I'm going to make that that
one change number two um is just a
couple of lines down uh on line 11
beginning on line
11 this is the um this is the section
that says the legislature shall recuse
him or herself from participation in any
official legislative activity only when
the legislator a member of the
legislator's
household and then it listed those three
items it wasn't n clear in the original
bill to me that you needed to satisfy
all of those and so that's change number
following change number
three
um and I'm not sure if I'm going
backwards or forwards here um I included
the language um
are not limited
to on both line
19 and
line
26 one of them had it
originally and one didn't I put it in
both of them but I don't remember which
one had it
original all that is doing obviously is
making it clear
to the reader
that um those aren't um exhaustive lists
there are other possibilities that
someone could
have that's all it does you look you're
looking puzzled at me uh representative
but um so that's change number change
number three and change number
four is on the last line of the second
page um effective date January 1st
2025 that was specifically asked for um
by the Ethics Committee I think um
reflecting the fact that
um and I'm and I'm thinking
both the house bill and the Senate
Bill both had a 30 days um effective
date on it um it was pointed out to me
in that ethics meeting that uh there
would be some difficulty in in well just
for one practical purpose crafting the
books for the next legislative session
um in time so everything an agreement
was made to say January 1st so that it
was clear that these were to be in
effect for the upcoming legislative
session and that's change number four
and that's what those this amendment
does
now um open for conversation questions
comments represent D thank you chairman
Hill I want to thank you for um having
me I just want to clarify something um I
will well I will say that your
suggestion number two which is found on
lines 11 and 12 um for the most part
meets the amendment that I had had
drafted to CL verify the language um on
those certain situations where the
person would have to recuse themselves
can you just for my own information um
give me a little more explanation of the
first change on um any political
subdivision within the state of New
Hampshire just explain that a little
more in depth of what that actually
means um sure um it would just as we are
excluding um someone that works
for
um back up just a second this this 65
this um Senate
amendment I liken it I gear it more
towards the employer employee
relationship than um what we crafted in
the house originally um this is this was
brought to um the table because of the
request um for for an opinion done by
Senator Carson primarily and her
relationship uh with her employer at uh
UNH yes UNH um so what they were trying
to do here um if I understand um my the
explanation I received is they were
trying to exclude from recusal anyone
that worked for the uh their employer
would be the state the federal
government the state of New Hampshire a
county and it was their understanding
that um because
no um Municipal
Employee would have qualified
anyway um using those uh three
qualifiers beginning on line 13 14 and
that there was no need for them to have
um the Municipal Employees included in
that uh definition under organization of
who was excluded that's my understanding
does that answer your question I think
so so that line any political
subdivision is meant to include anyone
on the municipal level that it would
qualify to correct great that that seems
to be the the phraseology that we use in
a lot of places all needed to know thank
you I appreciate the time
yep yes representative men um
so um I have a little bit of a concern
about the process um with that third um
change that was suggested um which adds
but are not limited to um I'm just a bit
concerned that if we don't kind of
outline these like specific areas of
influence
um I mean would it then be up to the
individual member of the general court
to say I don't fall in these categories
but I'm going to recuse myself or kind
of how how does that work on a practical
level
um welcome to legislative Administration
um we have been um dancing around with
definitions for three years or so and um
and it's virtually impossible in in my
estimation it's virtually impossible to
for us to have listed every possibility
of of every case that someone may be
sitting in reps hall or the Senate
chambers that would would fall under
that category it
so you may look at this as a copout but
um it it does
serve the purpose of at least alerting
people that even though they may not
fall into one of the named that they
that there are possibilities of other
occupations or positions that would also
qualify and I think the genius of uh oh
I'll hate that'll come back to me
somewhere along the lines but um the Gen
of um of the drafter of this um was
including the title saying facts and
circumstances tending to show
substantial influence
um to me that clearly indicates that th
this is not an exhaustive list um these
are these are uh every if if I learned
one thing in going to ethics committees
and and listening and reading uh
opinions from
them it's it's impossible to um foresee
every possibility that could come forth
so I think this is their best way of
doing that okay thank you for clarifying
sure yes representative wall thank you
Mr chairman I appreciate what you just
said for clarification because uh the
Ethics Committee has really struggled
with this for a long long time and I
agree with the chairman because because
there's no way we could create a whole
laundry list of every position and I
think inevitably people will be going to
Rich Lambert or or the Ethics Committee
to ask for further clarification as time
goes by but I think this is as close as
we could get at this time thank you
thank you um I'll just give you some
more of the background here um our
original
goal was to try to create something that
someone sitting in section three middle
of the row um and a bill is in front of
them have the ability to um decide for
themselves if there is an issue that
they need to recuse themselves for um
we've all been in a situation where
something a bill comes up that flew
under the radar for us personally and
didn't know that it was coming up and
all of a sudden you start thinking gee I
wonder if I have a problem with this
I've said this time and time again if
you think you have a problem with this
you should recuse yourself that's the uh
that's the catchall um to to me that's
how I would operate um having failing
that what we started with I think in the
very first conversation the very first
hearing was a was the idea of perhaps
even creating some kind of a decision
tree for that for a a new rep coming in
and orientation and hand them a tree
that says if you have issues with you
and your employer and you start
following down that way and and the same
thing if you have individuals in your
family that um have employers that may
be having um legislation that comes
before the before us in committees it
there seems to be the a need or desire
for that it's very difficult to do um
the more we worked with it so um I'm not
going to say this is an
exhaustive process um and this is the
outcome of that I'm going to say these
are um two significant steps forward one
in the Senate and one in the house um
that operate in different areas
um there still needs to be further work
there's there are other places we can go
this is darn good as far as I'm
concerned
representative evil I think it's darn
good
too uh well my day is made I don't know
what the rest of you are going to do for
the day but my day is made but I just
could you um just explain again the
rationale for pushing back the effective
date I think I followed most of it sure
um if you don't mind thanks and and and
we may want to actually bring in um um
more learned uh person from the Ethics
Committee actually we have on our our
committee a member of the Ethics
Committee but uh you came in I'm not
sure for this part of the conversation
uh the other day um they just uh they
just assumed um right from the jump that
um a 30-day effective date um was going
to be it was 60 in the original I
apologize I'll take that back 60 days um
they thought that that was going to be
um unworkable from their standpoint from
the Ethics Committee standpoint and and
it seemed from that conversation that
their goal was always um or they thought
our goal should be to have this ready
for the next legislative session um and
then I think it was Mr Lambert that
brought up the idea that yes we' have to
have new um guidelines printed and there
was some discussion over the color um
whether it's purple or not and um and
and so they were thinking that if they
could get this um ready for January 1st
that would be the acceptable date
um I also upon the drive home started
wondering I wonder if also there may be
some concern with the um the ethics
cases that they have before them now um
um applying that to it um anything that
changes um in the interim so that's
that's my guess I that part was not
brought up that was just from my own
head on the way home but I know when you
start changing rules Midstream there's
sometimes problems and and even having
this discussion in ethics knowing that
there were petitioners well I don't know
if that's what they're called but
um already there to talk about their
cases I'm sure they would be thinking
about how that affects their case any of
the changes that are that are coming
forth so it um truly I did not question
them on the on the January 1 date any
further because to me it is designed for
the next legislature not this
legislature so I had no re problem with
it representative I was speaking with
representative evil earlier and my only
question would be would there be a need
for this to be um go into effect for
organization day since we're all sworn
in the month
prior I don't want to I don't want to
Mud The Waters I'm just yeah I the
reality is we're sworn in as as
Representatives on December this coming
year um I'm getting a headshake no uh
from
Mr lamber can you maybe jump on the
sit reluctantly even I think the biggest
reason for holding back is because the
statute requires that the guidelines be
consistent with the statute and so we
need to amend the guidelines which is a
process in and of itself we'll probably
just in the past we've just
almost verbatim Incorporated any sort of
statutory change into the guidelines but
decisions would have to be made as to
where exactly the guidelines that would
go and language has to be agreed upon
and then the house and the Senate must
approve that
Amendment so um I don't know if they'd
be willing to do that on any sort of
veto day in the past that's not been the
case when
um when is that accepting
done in relation to organization day is
that done on or I my memory is not what
it used to be when do we normally accept
the guidelines when you vote on the
rules because the rules incorporate the
guidelines and that's the that's January
so process process is everything thanks
for clarifying that helps thank you oh
also the all of our opinions and
interpreted rulings need to be reviewed
because um some of them give guidance
which we don't no longer would apply for
example the interpreted ruling in the
back of the booklet is all about
conflicts of interest and so that should
be added into that um a provision about
when recusal is
required and they probably perhaps
they'll be an additional interpretive
ruling that would help be something
short and just about this that also
could be something that would be helpful
so all those things have to be done by
the
committee I think I actually should have
just had you come to the table first
rather than me stumbl through it I think
that would have been a smarter move live
and learn thank you can you hold for
just a second see if there's any other
questions I was just going to say though
before that's January works because
that's when we actually vote on the
things the house rules and and all those
things is December is is more the you
become the legislature it's January when
we actually start getting down business
so it shouldn't conflict from December
to January thank you representative
costal further discussion on
that okay
um
sure yeah we're in a work session we're
we're it's just us here we're not
talking to anybody else so um what what
I've also done
um is
taken this language um in this
amendment and asked the drafting
attorney to assume this language passes
as is and then give me a um welcome
representative not take any any seat is
fine
um and then give me back a merged
version of the house ped position for um
what the Senate has the our ethics our
house version of the ethics
Bill and this 605 Senate version as
amended with what I just gave you and
and and my like my likening is make this
a zipper so that we have one document
that um is containing the information
from both the house and the Senate
versions and the reason I did it was so
that we didn't have conflicts between
what 14
c44a said in one version versus what 14
CA ver Roman a said on the not Roman a
C4 d a said in the Senate version so
this is her attempt at that I'm not
sure whether that um clarifies or not
it's more done for me for a process um
or a a belt and suspenders approach
might thought is that if I could get
um this over to or have this in one
document then I don't almost care
whether the Senate tables our house
version or not or something we have one
bill that has both things in it and and
the house would be in control of of this
ethics package from the house and the
Senate so that's what this is um I'm
happy to hand it out or just have
discussions on it or anything
else that we have yes so essentially
you're saying uh the Senate is having
exactly what we're having we hope um so
that whichever version is adopted
reflects the other one where's the other
actually I have had thank you for the
question um because I have had
conversations with the Senate chair um
who has our house version and it is not
their intention obviously to not deal
with it um they intend to stranger
things have happened
so um what I hoped to do after this
conversation that we had is provide a
copy to the chair of the Ethics
Committee and let him amend or decide
whether he wants to amend the house
version to this so that it has both the
House and Senate
because these two don't work um in
opposite ways they they cover different
areas of the ethics um laws so one as I
mentioned earlier 605 deals more with
the employer employee relationship the
house version works more with the
individual personal um or in financial
benefits from a legislator so they're
not in they're not doing opposite things
they're doing s um simultaneously
they're doing different things so to me
it makes sense that at some point we're
going to have these merged I was going
to see if we could just pass it in that
version in both the House and Senate off
the bat so representative tki um do you
know off the top of your head the bill
number on the house version I was just
going to pull it up so I can see what
and I think we heard that they're having
that
hearing May 8th which
is what's that May 8th 9:30 in the
morning I think at State House 100 oh
okay I'm not I'm not aware um when I
spoke with the chair he wasn't sure when
he was going to have the hearing so but
but that's what this is if anyone
wants it or whether I I don't know
whether we should just set it aside and
know that if the House and Senate passes
it um this is what it'll ultimately look
like more than likely um or whether we
should uh take it up in exec session and
and pass it and then provide them a copy
of it um in the hearing on May
8th representative evil
I wouldn't mind taking a look at it I
mean basically what you're saying is
it's a mashup of 1388 and 65 but
nothing's really changed nothing changed
unless there was a mistake or something
um yeah only the only um and maybe um
our researcher can well I don't know if
you've had a conversation with OSS
attorney or not about it no okay um the
only thing that I was concerned about is
the the
um uh I didn't want one bill in some
area to conflict with another or not
make it possible to work um that's all I
was trying to do and try to do it in
advance rather than get to a point where
we passed them both and then find that
we either have to come back to do
something so that they actually fit
together I was trying to be proactive
that's all but yep I'm happy to hand it
out
time and I did confirm that the changes
that we just talked about are in this
one so it's it's
actually because we haven't voted on
those that Amendment yet um and I and I
think
I need
to I think I need to confirm with
representative tki um do we want to did
I go out of order should I have should I
have brought up the amendment that you
have here or is is that pretty much Tak
care thanks for your consideration I I
think with um my ranking members
approval that my amendment has been
absorbed into your first one okay all
right do you agree Mr chairman y uh may
I ask a question absolutely you thank
you very much didn't you want to add the
word and at the end of her it's
understood but it's better to clarify it
I can I can show you the what the
language
is I'm not sure well I guess if we're
actually drafting another amendment and
merging both and there's any tweaks made
all right I will pass this out just so
you can see
the clarification there was an extra and
I think that's it oh okay in the in the
section um where that's Incorporated on
change number two it yes change number
two if you look at line oh there is an
and after Roman two right there's a and
after line 14 I my draft has an and
after line 13 and it just says all of
the following so it be receives
Financial REM a from an organization and
holds a position to Expo and it's one
and however if there is going to be
another draft that would be the only
change yep I
I will say I did review this as best I
um Keener eyes than mine to make sure
that um something wasn't either
duplicated or dropped
or but but this is a uh an easy way to
do
it Mr chairman yeah could you just point
out the end of the first bill in the
beginning no you can't okay no because
they're truly a zipper oh well then I'm
not going to be much help well this is
what I'm saying it's very hard to do um
sure um as I told you our original goal
was to make this uh and getting to
representative menal bomb's point to get
this to the point where um the average
person could read this in section
three I'm not sure where where they yet
but
um but it
does as far as I can see and the places
that I looked it does incorporate all of
spots repr yeah Mr Lambert Mr
chairman I see a possible conflict um on
page one line 31 the word
only which line 31 you say yes the word
only so that part was language from
605 yeah so those are the only
circumstances where recusal is required
right later on there are other
and I did mention this to the vice chair
the other day that it it does seem when
you merge these things like like we have
done
um it would seem that something like
that would pop up that we didn't
anticipate when we drafted the house
that there would be a senate version so
um that that's one of them
um it
does I agree with you that it could
potentially
my only thought is if we're GNA all go
through this super carefully we might
not be able do it I know that's what I
wondered as well um I think it's a great
idea but yeah and and more from a
procedural standpoint than anything else
because it um I think it would save an
awful lot of floor time either in the
house or the Senate if all one or the
other group was doing was standing up
and saying the Senate has already passed
the combination bill so it renders ours
move we don't need to we don't need to
vote on this that saves or the reverse
if the house has pass both of them that
incorporated the changes in both were
done um procedurally it's just a cleaner
way to do it but I agree with the
interest of time it may not be the
although if it's something as simple as
this I don't know if that would be
picked up in enroll bills or not um
I you
know it it
seems I don't know maybe it's too clever
know we can do whatever you'd like um
why don't
we could you check to see if we have the
amendment yet on
um on the Marthur Fuller Clark bill
which number escapes
me
want I was trying to do it but the the
numbering has changed and it's not the
language is here's here's how I finally
looked at it it seemed to me the
language is all the same it's the
placement that was different so um I'm
not sure that there's anything more
than
um I don't know um Deep In The Weeds uh
conversation than than it is Mr chairman
basis yep I think maybe some of the
confusion might be that we have the
Preamble in this and didn't have it in
the amendment so they're having trouble
placing that so um yeah that's a good
point um all of line one through
line well 16 I guess um is the language
from the original House bill that
um that were the findings in other words
and the purpose that was um that comes
from the original not from Senate Bill
605 so um essentially Mr chairman that's
the preamble to the bill just so people
yes
yes on the original 1388 yep rep conable
sorry no no you're fine uh it's just a
minor minor thing on page two line six
um rightfully we don't have to recuse
ourselves for the budget but it says
shall not recuse and I'm one of those
shall means you must so shall not recuse
is telling me that I'm not allowed to
recuse myself on on you know what I'm
not that's already in the that should be
brought up next on May 8th in the uh
Senate version really yeah like it's
it's just to me I think it's just a
clerical legislator shall not recuse him
from the budget is saying I'm not
allowed to recuse myself from the budget
himself
I'm um you laugh but but in review of
all of the other states that um that Jen
put together for us more often than not
that is what they are doing is is making
them
yeah
um
yep would you mind thank
you
um I uh I think I'm of the mind and I'll
see what everyone thinks I'm of the mind
to set as side this amendment um and and
just deal with the original amendment
that we dealt with and and not bother
trying to be clever and merge these
things together where where is everybody
that bring I that would work I mean I
could easily drop this on them and say
by the way um here's what we've done in
committee it wouldn't have passed the
house by then but here's for your
own usage yeah and that gives more time
for other people to look at it I guess
okay see this is why we do work sessions
um all right I uh what is our plan right
now the plan is we have one more um one
more Amendment coming on the other Bill
I'm putting aside 605 for right now I
think we beat that horse um but thank
you Mr Lambert um you're free to go um
the
uh I will describe for you the amendment
um and then follow up with the when the
copies come um so on the other bill um
which is
331a that as you may or may not be aware
um was to authorize the historical
committee to accept a portrait of uh
Senator Martha Fuller Clark and hang it
in the state house um it has been
pointed out to us uh several times by
several different people that the
historical committee would like the
discretion of being able to hang things
things where they where they choose um I
guess in the interest of space Andor I
don't know what else um so I went to OS
originally with the amendment to just
change that state house to simply saying
at the discretion of the joint
historical committee the hanging would
be uh overseen by the by The Joint
historical committee while I was there I
tacked on um an
acceptance and mirrored the language of
the um of the Martha F Clark line and
just said the joint historical committee
um is authorized to accept a portrait of
Wentworth
cheswell um and oversee the hanging at
their discretion
um in the State House complex or
something like that so that's all that
the amendment has it's just those two
lines and then an effective date I guess
um but um if anyone wants background on
why we put in um when we're cheswell um
I think that was in the prior term was
it it wasn't last year was it prior term
yes you do so so um for those that
aren't aware Wentworth cheswell is in
some circles um called um the um the
black Paul reir um is one thing he was
known for there's other groups that um
believe and this is uh questioned I
guess um whether he was the first
elected official um first black uh
elected official in the United States um
and yet um we had a bill two terms ago
that ran into difficulty the house
passed it it went to the Senate the
senate had difficulty with it um for two
reasons one that we were being asked to
pay for
it um there are there more oh you have
some over there
um the original bill that the
legislature was being asked to pay for
the uh commissioning of a of a portrait
um
and that was one issue the senate had
the second issue was they didn't believe
it was brought up in testimony that they
didn't believe that there was a a
picture of uh ww worth cheswell that
they could replicate for a portrait so
um they substituted and sent back to us
an amendment to turn the portrait into a
plaque
um that didn't sit well with this
committee and um I think we even went to
Committee of conference over it um to
say what are you thinking and um and it
ended up dying with no one signing off
on the bill so this is a way of bringing
it back uh to the attention of um of of
us um and say that we do think that
there should be some portrait of the um
of Wentworth cheswell um hung somewhere
in the state house or hung somewhere in
the State House complex so that's uh
that's what the amendment in front of
you does you can see that um lines 11
through
14 um mirror lines three through six
except for the names
representative W thank you Mr chairman
thank you for all that you've been
offering
um I will say that we met with Senator
Susie this morning who said that
actually the Martha F Clark portrait ran
into some bumps in the Senate which
surprised me um I'm holy in favor of of
the legislation for us to accept the
portrait and or direct the historic
committee to accept the portrait I serve
on that committee um the committee has
to choose where can be
displayed and right now a lot of the
portraits are being rearranged in the
state house uh according to certain
priorities and we don't know in the
future what will be happening uh with
the various portraits and such um but
we're trying very hard to recognize
women in the state house at this point
and I'm fully in favor of the bill for
Marth 4: CL when it comes to adding WTH
cheswell we're fulfilling a commitment
that this committee made uh I believe
two years ago um because WTH jeswell I I
do have some facts on him yes he's known
as the black Paul Riv he was the first
elected person actually um they called
him a molato um because of his skin
color at the time uh but he was the
first of color to be elected to any
office in this country um what was chz
was a significant individual from New
Market there is a state plaque on a
stand in New Market near his grave uh I
remember one time when we were working
on this particular bill I went to the
research office and all four researchers
worked with me diligently one whole
afternoon trying to find some picture of
wentw ches and we I remember running up
to Paul Smith and saying hey we at least
have a picture of a descendant of his
near descendant you know one generation
down um all we're asking for is a
likeness of him um trying to come close
at least this gentleman really really
should be
recognized um because he was the first
personal color in the whole country and
from New Hampshire uh he was a
Mason uh he had a very distinguished
career well educated came from a good
family and certainly does deserve
recognition I don't have copies of what
I have here on him to hand out today but
um I I'm just reminding the committee
that we were committed to doing
something with this so I'm I I was I'm
supporting this amendment because I'm
totally in favor of the Martha F Clark
portrait coming forward uh for those who
haven't seen it in some room I think
it's State House 102 it's Donna suusi a
senator Donna susi's office um it is
really a fine fine portrait and she did
accomplish a lot here but it is up to
the historic committee to figure out
where to place it once we give them
authority to accept it um we're still
having some concern about a portrait of
w was jezell but there are people a lot
of people came and testified in favor of
the portrait we will not be paying for
it um I don't know if the offer still
stands it does Paul Smith is a Mason and
he's saying that the Masons will pay for
this so it's no obligation financially
to the state so I will support that as
well so um I'm asking for support on the
amended version thank you Mr chairman
thank you for the discussion we're in
work session still
so
um I don't uh I don't have anything to
add I appreciate the additional
information that uh that I was reminded
of um and I do
I don't think I knew that there was any
kind of difficulty in the Senate um with
the mark clerk I thought that I I
thought everyone signed on to it
actually so I I was a little surprised
to hear that this morning myself um they
all wanted it and I don't I um Senator
Su did not clarify I'm not aware of and
no one said there was yeah no one voted
against it but she indicated there were
some questions but we don't know but
passest nevertheless so now it's ours
okay well if there's no other
conversation about that um I will
suggest that we uh take a five minute
break um and um and then come back into
exact session and knock knock our final
two bills off the calendar and and get
going good five minutes uh
do we need to
don't you get your ducks in a row no
okay we we actually would like to have
uh two minutes here uh for getting our
clerk work put together so we'll be here
you can have the office
than
thanks we're in recess until
thanks
e
all right we're back um I will open the
exec session um and
recognize um Vice chair Shen for a
motion Senate Bill
605 yes um I move Senate Bill 605 ought
to pass representative she and mooves
Senate Bill 605 ought to pass uh
representative wall I will second that
seconds um the bill is open for further
Amendment i' recognize representative
Shen yes I move amendment number 20 24-1
1663 H ought to pass uh representative
she and moves I lost it
uh 1663
H um would you like to speak to your
motion or would you like someone else do
yeah I'll defer to the chair please um
fine um so Amendment 1663
H um made four
changes uh one or two of them um are
just more um cleaning up of the language
um
change number one on line eight um of
the Amendment added U political
subdivisions within the state of New
Hampshire to the uh list of other places
that um are not included in the
definition of
organization um that would be change
number one um change number two was
making clearer um
that all three of the um factors needed
to be
satisfied um in order for a legislator
to
recuse um number three um merely
um clarified the language that uh
the both
the um groups or people uh listed who
have substantial influence um are not
limited to that list it's not an
inclusive list likewise um in this
section below it um with facts and
circumstan stances tending to show
substantial influence it we also wanted
to make it clear that those are not uh
an inclusive list um and so we've also
made sure that the langu which says uh
but are not limited to on lines 26 and
27 and lastly is the effective date um
which was changed from 60 days um to
effective January 1 of 2025 reflecting
the fact that these changes um for
ethics and
recusal um are to be um part of the next
lucky bat of legislators that uh come in
for the next
session um that is the amendment uh is
there any further discussion on
Amendment
H would you like to speak to your second
no I would just say that given the
serious discussion we all had and the
particip concerns as well as support um
I would support um I hope everyone will
support the amendment thank
you seeing no further discussion I'll
ask the clerk to call a rooll on
Amendment
16638 thank you Mr chair on a to pass
for Amendment 1663 H rep uh Vice chair
Shen yes representative costable yes
clerk votes yes repr representative na
yes representative mcarter yes
representative tyy yes representative
kahill yes representative
wall yes representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Lane yes representative eil yes
representative metal bombb yes
representative Fox yes representative
torki yes and the chair
votes
yes 16 yay zero nay on the amendment
Amendment passes uh 1663 now we have uh
an ought to pass as amended on Senate
Bill
motion you already moved it actually um
all I need is uh further discussion
on seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
Coler
rooll on o to pass as amended for SB
605 um Vice chair Sheen yes
representative costable yes clerk votes
yes representative nder yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
kill yes representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Lane yes representative eel yes
representative manom yes representative
Fox yes representative tki yes and the
chair chair votes yes
160 unanimous uh any objections to
consent hearing none consent it'll be
just a minute here to reconfigure a few
things and we'll be back to you on uh
I didn't ask did anybody want to make
the motion on does anybody want to make
the
motion um does anyone on this side
ladies anybody want the motion does
may I clarify something I'm unsure if a
point okay I move for to pass well we
yet I'll have I'll have Vanessa make the
motion on the
amendment yes I move we adopt the
amendment thank you Mr
chair second
1808 okay we're back um opening the
exact session on Senate bill
331a um would
recognize the ranking member for a
motion uh thank you um I Mo are we on
the motion or we on the bill you're on
the bill and then I yes I would do ought
to pass as amended no just ought to pass
well I said ought to pass before so
no anyway I move out to pass thank you
second by representative mcarter bill is
open for for Amendment represent uh
recognize representative Sheen for a
motion yeah um I move amendment number
202478 H representative Sheen moves uh
Amendment
1708 H um is there a second second by
representative wall representative sheim
would you like to speak to your motion
chair thank you representative
she um so uh the amendment on um Senate
bill
331h um the original bill um authorizes
The Joint historical committee to accept
uh a portrait of um Senator Martha po
Clark um which I believe has already
been painted and is in um Senator susi's
office I think at the moment um and uh
and a change was made to that
original um bill by making sure that the
uh hanging of the portrait was and the
overseeing of that that hanging was done
at the discretion of the joint
legislative historical committee the
original Bill said that the painting had
to be hung in the state house um the
amendment changes that to uh at the
discretion of the joint legislative
historical
committee um in addition the amendment
adds a similar language uh to allow the
joint um legislative historical
committee to accept a portrait of when
worth cheswell um and oversee the
location of the hanging of that portrait
at the discretion of the joint um
legislative historical committee um and
that's the sum and substance of the
amendment uh representative wall would
you like further conversation about the
operation of the amendment yes thank you
very much Mr chairman some concern was
raised about uh frequency of changing
where the portraits are and this that
and the other umot lot of the portraits
were just put up by someone's judgment
back when without a lot of consultation
with the historic committee I'm not even
sure the joint historic committee
existed way back when um great thought
respect and consideration is given to
where the portraits are hung and we
don't get them that often uh most
recently we had the portrait of merilla
Ricker uh donated to the state it is at
the state house she was the first woman
who ever ran for governor she didn't
qualify to vote because she died just
before women got the right to vote
that's hanging on the first floor of the
state house um if anyone has any
questions and concerns about where uh
Senator Martha Fuller Clark's portrait
might be displayed uh they're welcome to
come to the Joint historic committee and
express opinions and I think that would
be very welcome um it's a bipartisan
committee and it's joint meaning the
house and the Senate so you have some
good people there thank you
thank you representative W um I concur I
think it's a great idea if people would
show up at the Joint legislative
historical committee um further
discussion on the
amendment seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the
role thank you Mr chair on Amendment
1708 for H SB
331 Vice chair Shan yes representative
costall
yes clerk votes yes representative nter
yes representative mcarter yes
representative K
yes I'm sorry I wrote the wrong uh rip
TIY yes okay rep rep um okay uh
represent I just totally fell off my
game rep nutting Wong yeah rep
turot yes representative Lane yes
representative eel yes representative
mbom yes represent Fox yes
representative tarki yes and the chair
yes okay 160 it's unanimous on the
202478 H passes uh we now have Senate
Bill 331 as
amended and that I
believe
was adopted oh was offered by you right
as an octopath for repres restive W oh
I'm sorry um further discussion as on
the bill as
amended I think we expressed our
opinions on this um seeing none I'll ask
qu call a rooll sen Senate bill
331a as
amended okay on the motion of octop pass
as amended um Vice chair Shen yes
representative
costable yes clerk votes yes
representative ner yes representative
Carter yes representative terney yes
representative kahill yes representative
wall yes representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Lane yes representative evil yeah
representative manal bom yes
representative Fox yes representative
tki yes and the chair chair votes yes
all right 160 on that hearing any
objection to
consent hearing none uh it will be on
consent
I think uh that ends our work for
legislation we do have however a couple
of um probably impromptu meetings coming
up uh one is going to be if any of these
um are changed and we need Concur and
nonc concur um and we also have the
existing bills that are over in the
Senate that we're working on legislative
youth advisory council is still being
worked on on um the others lose me
there's something
else um so this isn't going to be the
end of the committee but for now we've
done all the work I want to thank you
all for all of your hard work throughout
of the year um I also want to thank the
our very fine substitutes for today
thank you um get a little window on how
um
legislative Administration likes to work
as a on a bipartisan fashion uh
representative wall you have your like
well what can I thank you thank you Mr
chairman I want to thank all the
committee members it's a joy working
with you I want to thank all the
substitutes who came in today it was
really good of all of you to show up um
it's kind of tough showing up in a
different committee and getting up to
speed on the issues but you did it and
you did it beautifully I want to thank
the staff also and thank our our
leadership on the committee thank
you uh I Echo um our our staff is
phenomenal um I I actually
thought this is probably more than you
ever want to know I actually thought we
were in deep trouble when we lost Pam
smling as our researcher
um uh it it's a and one a and 1B I think
is what we have a very fine researcher
that has helped us enormously here um
likewise we also have a committee
assistant that has been very helpful I
always think some of this is good when
it's seen and not heard and everything
just moves smoothly sometimes that's the
best for as a assistant but our
researcher is
spectacular um I hate saying that
because now somebody will try to steal
her so that's not not good um anything
else that anyone else wants to bring up
any other concerns comments questions
seeing none um we are done for the day
have a nice